did you know that the initial person
that was supposed to play The Last of Us
guy and the girl it was supposed to be
Leonardo DiCaprio in a relationship did
you guys
it was thrown off the vibe did you know
it yeah different show where where no it
would have been an awesome show somebody
said that the same age difference is yes
yeah yeah
and his new girl yeah and then the
Father the guy and the girl and Ellie
Joel and Ellie there Leo would have
killed it in that role
if Leonardo DiCaprio was starring in it
with
a good that the girl it would have been
better 100 I agree no no no no because
he would have been [__] her
I'm not gonna watch
any episode he [__] her
I'll watch those for you I'm okay
you could watch Leo what do that what
it's acting bro you should know this
better than anyone
yeah
Hey listen listen listen yeah you get it
y'all weird bro y'all weird those
episodes will be Mark's wild things
right there
no that is a little crazy does Leo need
to chill son
a little bit it's a little bit y'all
need to call your mans out what what do
you want us to call him out I don't know
but that's weird white people don't have
y'all man's like you guys do yes you do
I don't know I don't know exclusive yeah
what he's trying to say is white people
we don't we're not responsible for all
whites yeah but you're responsible for
every black person ever and everything
you guys do exactly that's LeBron with
the championship like we did it yeah
exactly yeah we did I was in this gym
shooting with him
but Leo that's not our man know we
admire him not for that yeah but we
admire him for his ability to act you
know how hard is to act interested
around a 90 19 year old
you know how much maybe he's practicing
maybe he's practicing acting interesting
interested
you know I'm trying to help him yeah son
the girl is younger than Titanic no but
you know what's funny what younger than
Titanic what does that means
she was born
two born 2001 2004 2004 is great she's
never been on the earth while the two
towers were here she three years after 9
11 bro she never been on the planet she
wasn't even conceived she was still
sperm by the time Osama did that
because it wasn't even involved 50. son
she's got the perfect Alibi she was in
high school during the pandemic taking
classes over online okay well she might
got held back that's that doesn't
prevent them what you mean you might got
held back to two years how to do Florida
Virtual School or some [__] I don't know
she might have got held back that to me
I'm like the high school thing that's
whatever son I don't even know what's
going on I don't even know you guys are
debating Leo
right well it's creepy yeah it's creepy
now what none of us are doing right now
it's not illegal what none of us are
doing right now weird [__] what none of
us are doing right now is looking at her
Instagram because Dad is Gonna Change
maybe the way you think because we've
already done it you I mean some of us
are a little bit quieter than others I
ain't looking No 19 year old no
you're running nasty [__]
how old you gotta be to look at a 19
year old's Instagram because I know
you're 30. that's what I'm saying I'm
saying
I'm saying this guy this is crazy
I must say
10 10 to 15. once you go beyond 15. you
would look at a 15 year old whoa whoa
whoa whoa
first of all dude
you just said the 15 year old's the
cutoff I wasn't paying attention fully
yeah you said no you said 15's to cut
off clip it I don't know
that's what you just said speak more
carefully yeah
he's too busy [__] having a bricked
up I'm watching this 19 year old
what you mean
forever but not him so
don't get her Instagram
I think this is it oh I mean
thank you
I told you hold on I told you y'all look
cool this is crazy
19 where that ain't 19. really is a
sniper
bro
come on make the pictures
that ain't nice
come on that girl looked 32. son she's
1932. she ain't 19 bro she 19. I don't
know what's happening somebody I think
she's 19. don't go too back too far
[Music]
that's all for the same year this is all
fine
this is a this is an of age person she's
allowed to go to war I mean Leo not that
bad guys
after 18 age a number bro whoa
hey he's gonna fight the Chinese bro no
but look at this if a chinese sends
another balloon we gonna send her and
her balloons over there [__] Chinese
is that what we got two out out is she
old enough
we're not I don't know oh they're the
right answer
this is a [__] up headline Leonardo
DiCaprio is not currently dating a teen
what does that mean I don't know and
then literally the picture Leo and a
team who was allegedly not dating
son that is wild
what is happening is she just try not to
get sued is she a teenager is she not a
teenager she is a teenager she's 19.
she's 19.
why'd you say he's not dating a 19.
so the headline says she's not currently
dating a teenager okay
when he was younger then 43 he's 48 now
is this like a sarcastic thing I don't
know I think basically they're just what
the [__] age is she now she's 19. so
then he is dating but it's not a
confirmation that they're together so
it's just rumors so it's allegedly they
don't want to get sued so they're saying
this is the 19 year old that Leo keeps
hanging around but they're not dating
you can't even be around a 19 year old
without the Assumption of dating that's
good she just has a book of puns like
what's wrong with that yeah nothing
wrong with that was just telling him
that's it
come on Bros
this is the one time that white people
age and bad works out for you because
this [__] that's a great thing a little
girl a [__] yes
[Laughter]
if we go down one birthday if you see a
[__] candle on a cake in this goddamn
[__] Instagram scroll you're going to
prison you're a wild boy for that one do
you want to pull up fee picks no not at
all come on bro
Jones
[Laughter]
might be too old
oh that's funny oh that is funny I might
have gone back to that's my bag
s
I'm sorry everybody watching I'm sorry
Leo why'd you do this he didn't even
have to Google that [__] he got it ready
Leo can't even stand next to a woman
without people thinking that they're
going out the audacity the audience yeah
bro there's got to be something sexist
about that why can't we talk about that
that's sexist to assume they have sexual
intentions with every girl he's near
yeah that's true why can't he just be
friends with a young Buckaroo why would
anyone make his intentions with this
girl
sheesh you saw a picture of him in the
bathing suit standing next to her yo
chill out yeah he's wild no his body's
wild what do you mean
he's trying to get out of the house
so when we add him in a spin cycle the
other day Okay and we were called I was
calling him Uncle Luke yeah this
[__] was get this [__] child
up I'm sorry Mark come on so we had
miles of the spin cycle because he
thought he was doing some wild [__] that
he couldn't remember at the [__]
karaoke party okay this [__]
started texting me he's like yo who's
Uncle Luke like is that a good thing is
that a bad thing so how am I gonna come
off yo I gotta read this [__]
thought he was going through it and then
he was like wait is this the same Uncle
Luke that Drake said in his song and I
was like get out what he's like oh okay
boy it's a compliment guys what the [__]
kinda anyway look yeah it's a comment a
little bit Yeah listen listen listen
Leo's out here doing Leo things
you know what I mean nah it for Al it's
a little too much it's a little too much
you think that he needs to stay I think
the older you get the larger the
Spectrum gets in other words a 60 year
old dude can be with a 35 year old woman
I believe and I think that you're okay
with it yes yeah yeah so he just isn't
expanding his Spectrum yeah accordingly
teenagers wow bro that's wild that's
wild right for 48 yes I don't even care
if you it's wild older but not we saw
the IG that's all I'm saying wow for
that when you saw the IGN
you gotta consider that I think
it's one year legal you have one year
cushion so there's no illegality issues
you guys are uh ethically ambiguous on
it wait wait I'm not in here
Indians is rapists
to quote you that [__] don't look 19.
that's a whole ass [__] right there
that's God damn all right this is true
she does not look like you look 19. and
I'm sure that he was quite frustrated
when he found out yeah right he was like
he was Chris he was like I wish you
looked I wish you were the age you look
yeah
if I found out late he was Furious he
probably thought she was 24. NDA and he
was like I gotta get my mom to do this
yeah
and then he was like well why would you
need
and yeah he was pissed off and he
[__] grounded her
yeah exactly that was the whole thing
how do you ground his girlfriend's Loki
yeah I think you can really
yeah
on the ground the baby in the corner
yeah you just said go away yeah if you
need to do things that puts a little
bibs on them when they're going out to
eat and like applesauce
is quite possible he's older than her
dad there's a 29 year age Gap so if the
dad had her before 29 he's older than
the dead call me daddy
let me tell you something if you're a 19
year old girl dating 48 year old guy
you don't know how old you're [__]
dad
exactly how much older I am
my wife and Dad failed
I'll tell you that right now you ain't
watching
[Laughter]
is a maniac yo what we gotta do is keep
this part in yeah he's gonna ask is that
yo can you just cut that [__]
okay leaving that part really okay boy
okay boy I see you so is my wife I'm
fairly certain
oh I just need to get her permission and
then
I don't like this because the girl's
Israeli and there's she's a beautiful
Jewish woman that could be no no no no
no don't cut it there fast forward and
pass it right there fast forward what he
said you said you don't like her because
she's Israeli and now she's a beautiful
Jewish girl and that she could be with
amazing Jewish guy I don't think
Leonardo DiCaprio is Jewish he is Jewish
he is is he Jewish
he's in Hollywood yeah no he's fake his
last name is fake his last name is like
dershowitz or something like that yeah
bro okay look it up there's no way he's
changed his name bro come on bro it's
Jewish bro
dude
if he wasn't do it and you know what I'm
saying
he's not Jewish yes he is look right
there there's a camera last name this is
DiCaprio I don't think he's Jewish
well you'll learn a new thing every day
it's a very Italian last name right yeah
that's pretty Jewish yeah is Wilhelm
Jewish or German or German they were hot
enough not Jewish
situation you were either on Jew or
German side you know you never know who
knows you really don't know it is such a
wacky thing what could it be who knows
but all that to say I think she could be
with an amazing Jewish guy like dove
I think it's [__] up that uh he's
taking all these Jewish models he really
is yeah and he is defiling them I don't
know what he's doing I mean we don't
know no I mean I think Lee was probably
a good lover yeah I think he's the three
guys I think he's a great lover only
he's an evil you know he's a good lovers
yeah actually no I don't I don't think
he's extremely giving
I don't see him as like a gracious you
could be not a giving lover and a good
lover probably that's okay see this is
how I know yeah
[Laughter]
I'm very giving that's the only way
I mean I'm getting no other way I got to
be giving yeah yeah yeah
I'm not given with the genitals
no yeah oh absolutely well it's no fun
like this